hey guys welcome back to brand-new food
we're back on four and the season nine
executions have just went live so I have
some footage of all the executions of
all 22 heroes if you want to know what
time stamp or where your specific hero
is you can check the description down
below I have the time of when they show
up in the video and what the move is
supposed to be called that you should be
buying for season 9 so I got you all
covered for that we're doing Knights
Vikings Samurai then the woodland to
finish off let me know in the comments
your top 3 executions might have to be
shaman shougo key and shinobi personally
just let me know in the comments below
it's way too early for this so I'm gonna
go to bed peace out guys enjoy the rest
of the video like the view do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being bounced changes here update
spatulas and leaks so do want to be kept
up with everything out to date with on
for honor
definitely sub to me with that enjoyed
[Music]
you